unless you've been living in a doomsday
bunker without CNN you've probably
noticed the Republican Party has gone a
little bom bom bom bom puff message it
used to be the grand old party now it's
going on pathological they're so far off
the deep end they've made their guru the
Gipper look like a liberal lightweight I
believe in the idea of amnesty for those
who have put down roots and who have
lived here even though sometime back
there they may have entered illegally
Rick the GOP of today is no longer the
party of fiscal conservatism tax breaks
and social programs for their third
wives they're the obstructionists the
caucus blockers the guys who won't pass
legislation unless it contains the word
Sharia or baby parts but Republicans
didn't always used to be so Jeunesse a
trump if their revenue yeah I don't want
to see a whole thank it six and eight
year old kids being made to feel that
they're living with outside the law and
it was Republican Richard Nixon who
established the Environmental Protection
Agency we can make 1972 the best year
ever for environmental progress oh and
on accepting Muslims in America right
after 9/11 George W Bush said Islam is
peace and that's from the guy who
invaded to predominantly Muslim
countries so what happened since the
last presidential election Republicans
have pulled the country so far to the
right Dick Cheney almost seems endearing
partly thanks to the 2009 rise the Tea
Party movement an economic recession
groups like Isis freaking people out and
oh yeah the election of the first black
president we've been left with the
perfect storm for bom bom bom bom sure
the politically unstable have always run
for office but the republican
establishment candidates with less
extreme views tend to pull through in
the primaries this time around though
Trump and Trump Lite are the
frontrunners and there's no sign their
momentum will end and even if many
conservatives disagree with their
politics they're keeping quiet about it
some are even starting to resign
themselves to a trump nomination big
donors the head of the Republican
National Committee and several
establishment Republicans are saying
they'll vacuum if that's what they've
got to do which seems a bit like
political suicide for a party that
admits it needs voters of color and the
youths to survive
remember after Barack Obama beat captain
white burns by landslide in 2012 the RNC
commissioned a report that in a nutshell
said just that after all the GOP has
lost the popular vote in five of the
last six presidential elections and by
2060 five whites will no longer be the
majority and that's even with the
Duggars the Palin's and every spawn of
the entire duck dynasty but this
election throws demographics to the wind
in fact it's almost the GOP s last-ditch
effort to remain relevant to white
people so what's going to happen to the
Republican Party are we witnessing a
political extinction like the
know-nothings or the wings or can
republicans evolved beyond bom-bom
bom-bom of course they would have to
agree on evolution first